I was I was working in law and I decided
that I was not enjoying the practice of
real estate law I I went and I quit and
I had no job I was about to get married
we had just taken a a mortgage on a
house and I took a job for one-third to
pay to work at talk radio network and
the deal was that I would do some
in-house legal work half the time and
half the time I would learn the radio
business they had basically won on the
same-sex marriage issue and everybody
thought okay battle over like everybody
weapons down go back to your normal
business like no no we have another step
here and the next step is that we're
going to teach our version of sexual
orientation and gender identity to your
kids and that is going to include the
idea that gender is fully malleable and
on a spectrum and completely socially
constructed he's 76 years old he has no
ability to control his mouth or his
typing fingers he has no sort of actual
plan to win I mean he literally
complained in 2020 that he was robbed of
the election voter fraud but no one will
ask him a simple question how do you
plan to unrob the election in 2024 do
you want to vote for the guy you love
but who's likely to lose or join to vote
for somebody who you like but is
significantly more likely to win
foreign
[Music]
do you like romantic novels no in my
countrymen who read romantic novels are
executed which is correct this is why we
don't have men with pink hair or women
with unshaved armpits what mate chill
out how about if the character was woke
even worse Lennon would have been
spinning his glass case but what if it's
satirical my country would do not have
satar laughing is not allowed if you
want humor
well if you were blessed with a sense of
humor and enjoy a bitingly funny
takedown of romance novels and World
culture then you have to read Danielle's
passion a new settler that follows a
young ivy league grad as she battles
white supremacy the patriarchy and late
stage capitalism in the hellscape that
is Irvine California this is not natural
live laugh and love to the eyes of one
of your Mall superiors suffer every
microaggression judge every co-worker
betray every family member as if you
were doing it yourself and come out
feeling just as smug this sounds like
almost Russia now I'm interested in this
book it's comedy done the right way no
lectures no messages no characters
banging on about the same tired talking
points satire as it's meant to be so so
if you want great book go to Amazon and
click on link below we also recommend
you buy Tide moderates other books won't
fragility and a little book of woke
jokes click on Luke and laugh like
you're reading warranties
hello and welcome to trigonometry on the
road from the USA I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kison and this is a show for
you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our brilliant
guest today is the co-founder of the
daily wire Ben Shapiro welcome to
trigonometry thanks for having me
appreciate it oh it's an absolute
pleasure we've been looking forward to
this for for a while now uh thanks for
coming on the show thanks for Lending us
your studio here
um listen the question we always ask of
all of our guests and you're very well
known most of the people watching this
will know you but what is your journey
through life how did you get here
because a lot of people won't know
actually many of the things you did when
you were starting out so give us an
overview so I mean the kind of short
version is that I went to college when I
was 16 and I skipped a couple of grades
I went CC alone now 16 and I thought I
was going to major in double major in
music and genetic science because as a
violinist a pretty violinist at the time
and um I stepped on campus and I opened
the student newspaper and there was an
editorial comparing Ariel Sharon then
the prime minister of Israel to era the
Nazi and and so I walked into the the
newspaper and I said I'd like to write a
counter to this because this is nonsense
and they said okay sure so I wrote a
counter to that that sort of became a
point Counterpoint column that I do
every couple of weeks and then it turned
into just a regular column after a
couple of years of that or a year and a
half of that I actually went to my dad
and I was like do you think my stuff's
good enough to be in a real paper and he
said yeah let me do some research and he
um he came up with a place called
Creator Syndicate which is a syndicator
of columns to hundreds of newspapers at
the time it was people like Molly Ivins
on the left and David Limbaugh on the
right and and so I just submitted my
stuff cold and they called me three
weeks later and they said we want you to
have a syndicated column so it's 17 I
was the youngest indicated columnist in
the country my parents had to sign the
contract because I was a minor and and
so I started writing columns and I said
like solidly 75 to 80 of the dumb crap
I've ever said or written was like in
that period before when you're 17 and
when you're 22. yeah because you're
trying to get attention and because you
think that you're a lot smarter than you
are when you're 17 or 18 years old which
you now only recognize in in retrospect
and your brain isn't fully developed
exactly so and again in in a place where
you're trying to gain attention the
thing you do is say the thing no one
else will say which sometimes is good
and a lot of times it's really stupid uh
in any case I I finished I finished UCLA
I go to Harvard Law School uh I wrote a
couple books while I was while I was
there so by the time I finished Harvard
Law I had three published books uh and
syndicated column I was working in law I
came back to LA I got married uh I was I
was working in law and I decided that I
I'd always continue to do the column I
was always doing political stuff but uh
I was not enjoying the practice of real
estate law particularly because I came
out of Law School in 2007 which was like
the worst time in human history to go
into the real estate market uh so I
would sit in this really nice glossy
office overlooking Century City and do
nothing like all day and after 10 months
of this and being berated by the
superiors for not billing hours because
number one there's no work in number two
my whole thing is I work fast and the
legal industry is about do not work fast
work slower so we can build more hours
to the client I I went and I quit and I
had no job I was about to get married we
had just taken a a mortgage on a house
and I took a job for one third of the
pay to work at talk radio network and
the deal was that I would do some
in-house legal work half the time and
half the time I would learn the radio
business I would actually get up at 4 30
in the morning I'd help write monologues
for hosts I would cut all the audio for
people like actually do the audio
cutting on the show cut all the clips uh
all that kind of stuff I worked there
for for a few years since three years
and then ended up as editor at large of
Breitbart which was because I'd known
Andrew Breitbart for a long time going
back to when I was actually at UCLA
Andrew lived in Brentwood and so we used
to or Westwood and so we used to you
know get together we'd become friends
and we came out in a larger Breitbart
during this time I'm still writing books
and everything the first sort of big hit
the thing where I where I became you
know relatively famous because you're
laboring B level obscurity and politics
like us
and and you didn't even challenge it
just enough today yeah yeah you're
absolutely right assessment is correct
exactly and uh and then there's there'll
be these kind of moments and that's the
moment where like everyone goes oh my
gosh she's like an overnight success now
we know and for me that was that famous
Piers Morgan interview that I did 2013
on CNN where now peers and I are
actually pretty good friends but but
back then he had me and it was like the
day after he'd interviewed Alex Jones on
gun control and he expected that I was
going to be like Alex Jones and I'm
fundamentally not like Alex Jones and so
that interview didn't go great for him
and uh and there are all sorts of
Articles a lot of attention all of a
sudden on that and at this point I'd
already met my business partner Jeremy
boring a couple of years beforehand we'd
talk about you know trying to get sort
of an entertainment company up and
running
um but the idea that we had at that
point was that Jeremy was going to be
kind of the talent guy and I was going
to be the legal and business guy because
I had a degree from Harvard Law I'd
actually been Executive Vice President
of this radio company I went from being
like in-house counsel to that and uh and
so after that Piers hit he called me up
on the phone and he's like we've got
this completely backwards you're the
talent and I need to do the business and
that's when that fundamental shift sort
of took place and we started working
with David hordes Freedom Center we
launched a web culture with Revolt which
was sort of the predecessor to daily
wire and that was a um reverse Media
Matters the idea was we didn't like what
Media Matters was doing and we
explicitly said this in our in our sort
of opening statement and we said that
the only way to get Media Matters to
stop forcing boycotts is to just do it
to the other side until they realize
this is a bad idea weapons down and
mutually assured destruction was the
basic idea of it we did that for for a
couple of years and then we had a um a
pretty funny sort of board meeting that
ends in our careers over there which was
Jeremy had discovered that social media
was actually a place that you needed to
be this is 2015. and uh and he said you
know there's some kind of holes in the
market here like you can actually start
to build a brand on social media but we
need a million dollars if you give us a
million dollars then we will build you a
money machine for all time we were at a
board meeting and it was a bunch of
people between the ages about 75 and
death and none of them understood what a
computer was let alone what the internet
was let alone what Facebook was and so
they said what's your business plan and
Jeremy explained it now I'm like a fast
talking Jew Jeremy is a slow talking
Southerner from from Texas so between us
I've called them before the stupid
Whisperer because I'll say a thing it'll
go right over people's head Jeremy will
say it's slower but with a Texas accent
everyone go oh that's him he earned that
nickname in a conversation with a
congress person actually uh the stupid
Whisperer anyway
um he uh he tried to explain the plan
and it went right over their heads and
they turned to me and they said what's
the plan and I took a I was very
agitated by this point because it's been
going for like an hour and I took out a
napkin I said here's the plan dollar
sign Arrow Facebook Arrow website Arrow
back to dollar sign we're going to spend
money on Facebook it's going to direct
traffic to the website that's going to
be the advertising and subscriptions
Arrow back to dollar sign and then we're
just going to reinvest and that's going
to be how we do our business they fired
Jeremy the next day uh and I I quit in
solidarity and then we took that
business plan out to the market we got a
little bit under five million dollars in
uh in seed investing uh and we were
profitable at month 18 is for daily wire
uh we were profitable at month 18. we've
been profitable ever since we've
operated purely off of cash flow with no
outside with no outside
Investments until this point and we are
generating about 200 million dollars a
year in annual revenue amazing it's an
amazing story I want to ask you more
about the daily wire but you mentioned
Andrew Breitbart and um I was wondering
because you know you get that thing with
like the bill hicks's of the world the
people who die young they always get a
lot of credit and that's what happened
with Breitbart what do you make of his
impact on Politics on your own was he a
big influence for you and what would you
make of his impact on the culture we
were good friends I mean the thing with
Andrew was and I said this to a lot of
people I spent a fair bit of time with
Andrew and you know helped him with a
bunch of big projects but if you met
Andrew for five minutes you knew him
about 95 as well as I did he kind of
reserved himself for like one close
friend whose business partner Larry
Sullivan and his family
um but you know everybody else who was
kind of the same too it was if you met
you for five minutes you got his entire
life story knew everything about him he
was very enthusiastic uh the the impact
that Andrew had on a lot of people was
he really helped connect a lot of people
there are a lot of people in different
places where he helped make the
connections which is why he actually was
one of the founding forces not just
behind Breitbart but obviously he was
involved in Drudge Report and also he
helped found Huffington Post right so
like half the internet was founded at
least in some large part by by Andrew it
wasn't as though he was sort of Guru you
go to you know for like life advice it
wasn't really like that it was he was
somebody who you went to if you want to
be connected with another person and
then he had sort of an interestingly
eclectic view of the world every he was
really a lot of fun he was really a
sweet guy that by the end his image had
changed so much because of the Dynamics
of politics that you see him doing the
war kind of a war hashtag War you know
the angry pictures of Andrew and all
that sort of stuff here in the end that
fundamentally is not who Andrew was and
if you talk to anybody who knew Andrew
for a long time the image that comes to
mind of Andrew for most of us is that
there's a YouTube video where he was
literally just rollerblading around
Santa Monica just talking to people and
he'd like take people like let's go to
Applebee's and just sit down with people
and talk with them that was Andrew's
unique gift is being able to connect
with people that way and he he never
thought that he was better than anybody
else which is why I think he was able to
connect really well with people but as
far as sort of the the kind of General
contributions connecting people and then
the the argument that he made which
wasn't unique to him but he sort of
popularized the culture was Upstream of
politics and that you need to get
involved in the culture fight uh which
obviously has had some pretty
significant ramifications
indeed so Ben you set up the daily wire
what's the modus operandi of the daily
wire why did you set it up and what are
you trying to do to the culture so we
set it up with the idea that we were
going to provide not only a media
alternative but that we were going to
actually wage the culture War we're
going to get into the culture like the
long-term goal was
to do what we've actually been able to
achieve we we have created a
distribution Network for product that
goes beyond just politics so we always
thought of ourselves not as a political
company with a marketing we thought of
ourselves as a marketing company that
does politics and that was sort of a
different way of doing it and that's
because when Jeremy and I first met he
was running a charitable organization
called declaration entertainment his
theory was basically crowdfund movies
and the problem was he would make he did
he made a movie for like I don't know 80
000 or something and then he had no
distribution Network so just kind of
languished there and it died and he and
I both realized well actually you have
to build the distribution Network before
you can provide the content for that and
so the basis of daily wire was you go in
with this really strong marketing
strategy you provide the market with
what it wants which is an alternative to
kind of Legacy Media narrative and
you'll find success there that there
were some successes that we obviously
didn't see coming if you look at our
original business plan we've been trying
to dig this up for years the original
business plan had slotted for my podcast
for example I think we had slotted that
like three years in we'd have a hundred
thousand listeners like it was it was
really like we were way off our
estimates for the growth of my content
in particular were off by orders of
magnitude
um yeah but that that happens with
talents right I mean you you think that
somebody's going to be a level they end
up in a level sometimes you pick
somebody you think they're an a level
they're a d like that just happens so we
had some we got lucky with some of the
sort of breakout material
um but again the main philosophy was be
hard-hitting uh be openly conservative
we don't try to pretend that we're
objective we're not objective we have a
specific and clear point of view uh I
for the first three years of the website
wrote literally every headline that was
on the website I would get up in the
morning I would assign 30 pieces I would
write every single headline because this
is one of the things that I was good at
uh and uh and then we put up those
pieces on the website I would do the
podcast
I was at the beginning of
of daily wire I was working several jobs
at one time I was doing like six hours
of radio at one time plus the daily wire
plus I was still doing some stuff for
Breitbart at the very beginning
um but yeah I mean the kind of mission
of daily wire was
be very clear about your principles and
then aim toward eventually being able to
effectuate cultural change across a
series of different millions and what is
a cultural change that you want to
influence I mean I think that we have I
would say we work along kind of two
lines one is the anti-left line of
broaden the discourse I've tried to make
a point of talking to people across the
political aisle which is why if you
watch my Sunday special I'll have on
people like Anna kasparian we'll just
chat for for an hour and a half or Larry
Wilmore or Jason Blum like I'll have on
pretty much anybody to have those
conversations we wanted to make sure
that you know that everybody's been sort
of siled off we wanted to say that those
conversations are totally doable and
haveable and they can be totally fine
and that's why in 2015 2016 I was kind
of considered part of the short-lived
intellectual dark web right it was this
idea that there were a bunch of us who
disagreed with each other I think I was
the only registered Republican in the
group contrary to sort of New York Times
in public opinion uh and uh we you know
we're all talking with one another and
it's like me and Sam Harris and Joe
Brogan and Dave Rubin and and a couple
of Eric Weinstein and a couple others
and um so it's broadened the political
debate was one open the Overton window
because the Overton window had closed
really tight 2016 27 2018. there's a
real move toward you can't say things
and now we cannot say things you can't
have conversations and if you do have
those conversations you will be expelled
from the movement it was more from
significantly more from the left than
from the right I think you've seen some
similar movements from the right
actually recently but I think that
you've seen it a lot more from the left
overall so that was mission number one
mission number two is I I am
conservative we are a conservative
company and so we have principles on
actual political issues ranging from
things like abortion to traditional
marriage to the value of religion in
life to free market economics and we're
not going to be shy about about our
agenda and we're not going to try to
hide our agenda now when it comes to our
entertainment content you know we've
been trying to produce movies that
aren't chiefly non-political in
orientation because our main contention
is that we all we have to do to have
Market space is make stuff that's not
political and because Hollywood has
gotten so political that if we just make
something that's like down the line cop
show in 2023 that's now considered
political right because the cops are not
evil and so you know that's opened some
space for us to operate this is kind of
what's happened with us in terms of like
Jeremy's chocolates or or Jeremy's
razors right those companies which were
launched you know like basically
Jeremy's razors had some thoughts with
but Jeremy's chocolates was not only on
the spur of the moment it was like we
put together the ad campaign for that
that day we did not have a chocolate
supplier we sold we've sold that 600
thousand seven hundred thousand
chocolate bars just because all we said
is we're a chocolate butter that doesn't
want to preach to you right so like the
we don't want to preach to you is
actually part of the cultural space so
you know I think that that lives halfway
between message one which is open the
Overton window and message two which is
we are conservative is that sort of
third halfway message which is there
does need to play be a place for not
politics right which is like you go into
your store you don't want to be preached
to you just want to get a product you
want to be on you know Amazon web
services you shouldn't have to pass some
sort of political litmus test to have a
neutral service provider provide you a
service so that's something we've been
pushing yeah well that's something we
agree on and try to do ourselves and
with that success that you've had and
with the attention that you've generated
and with the clear positioning of of the
brand that you have uh you know we
interviewed Dan Crenshaw this interview
will go out before dance uh but uh there
is way more security at the daily wire
than there is in Congress yeah right and
this ties into what's happened very
recently with Matt Walsh's emails and
Twitter and everything being hacked
where you guys paint painted or someone
has painted a Target on your back and
they're really coming after you now why
is that Ben because all the things
you've articulated as an outside
Observer I'd agree with I'm not a
conservative down the line but I respect
those views they're allowed to be aired
without people being threatened docs Etc
so why is that happening I think that
you know the situation has gotten so
polarized in the United States that that
as we as as more and more radical issues
come up and as you are strong against
radicalism there's always going to be
kind of a small group of people I don't
want to make it out to be like it's
everybody but there are small groups of
people who actually will get violent and
and that's you know for me went back to
like 2015. I was the number one target
of anti-Semitism online across 2016 I
had to full have full-time security I
still have basically full-time security
at this point as you've noticed Matt has
full-time security now uh he's been you
know threatened many many death threats
very specific death threats obviously he
had not just his phone hack but like
everything hacked including his email uh
you know the sort of targeting effort is
I think it's rooted in a belief that
because identity politics has decided
everyone puts their focus in the phrase
identity Politics on on the sort of the
idea that that your politics is that
that your identity is your politics but
in many ways it's the reverse your
politics has become your identity and so
if you have a political point of view
and someone offends you they have
attacked you they're seeking to destroy
you right this is the sort of language
Matt's obviously touching upon this with
the Trans issue when Matt says something
like well you say that you're a woman
but you're clearly a biological man
you're not a woman somebody will say
well you're erasing me you're this is an
attack on me and he'll say well it's not
an attack on you you're a person you're
standing there I'm not attacking you'll
say no no you're attacking who I am at
my core and that's a threat to me and so
when people decide that they're going to
perceive argument as threat in that way
then they tend to get more violent and
and that's you know that's not just me
Jonathan Hyde says this right when he
talks about microaggression culture the
idea that that I have been attacked by
your words your words are a form of
violence I now get to respond with
actual violence that sort of you know
Temptation I think has grown
dramatically in the society and then I
think the internet's made pretty much
everything worse as someone who makes
another living on I mean I make my
living on the internet um my kids will
not have access to the internet I hope
until they're about 18. no I'm the same
I just had a son he's 11 months old and
I'm already like we're doing interviews
with people just to like find out
exactly when would be the right time and
all of that I totally get it and how are
you gonna handle the map Wars situation
because I I we've met Matt I don't know
him personally but I I don't know a
single person that I can think of who
can survive 20 years worth of emails
being leaked because you know the stuff
that we all thought and said and joked
about 20 years ago is just in this
current environment yeah I mean he can
survive because we've got us back
because we understand that and we're not
firing him
I mean end of story like the reality is
that you can only be canceled by the
people who have the ability to cancel
you the left yelling at Matt isn't going
to cancel him the only people who can
actually cancel Matt are the people who
pay him right and his fans and none of
those people are going anywhere because
they all understand what this is which
is an attempt to discredit and Destroy
somebody for the great sin of saying
true things about biological sex and the
differences between men and wait a
minute and you know so I I don't I I
told him whatever give you sort of him
being like a pedophile or something then
yeah or committing some sort of
egregious crime no
I mean no that's it because guess what
I'm not of the opinion that stuff that
you say in confidentiality to your
spouse or your friend or that you email
to somebody in in confidentiality that
this is the the sole representation of
you and I'm really sick of a culture
that says that sort of stuff because
it's not true it really isn't the the
version of yourself that you present to
the public is actually the most
considered version of yourself because
you actually have to consider those
things what you say you know to a buddy
you make a a stupid racial joke or
something and that comes out the reason
that you didn't say it out loud is
because you know it's socially
unacceptable okay so what rule did you
actually violate yeah does this make you
like a terrible person or does it make
you somebody who like says rude jokes to
your buddies is it is like the is the
end of the world is be lie some deeper
truth about you I just I just don't buy
into the idea that what you say in
private is significantly more important
than what you say in public I think
usually it's the reverse
that's such a good point because we
don't live in that culture why do you
think the whole trans conversation is so
toxic
I mean it shouldn't be I think because
it is there really is no gray area is
the answer I mean you either believe
this thing that is fundamentally untrue
in my opinion or you and and just
actually or you or you don't believe the
thing uh and the this is a people want
fealty on this issue they don't want to
have a discussion about the issue right
because there are actual conversations
to be had about like for example how do
you treat trans people who identify as
Trans in public that's that's a real
issue like okay you know should they be
able to be fired if they're in this
position versus if they're in that
position should there be laws on the
books about what kind of bathroom views
right those are all sort of pragma
pragmatic discussions that you can have
about the risks and rewards of various
policies and their edge cases in which a
trans man was transitioned when he was a
teenager looks a lot more like a woman
versus like a big hulking dude who just
says he's a woman who's going into a bat
right like there are edge cases there
that can theoretically be discussed but
that's not what the conversation is
about the claim that the trans Community
is now making is that any man at any
time for any reason can say that he is a
woman and we must respect that and treat
him as though he is a woman because he
is in fact a woman any a woman as they
have now defined it is a person who
identifies as a woman that's as Matt has
pointed out quite properly completely
circular I mean there there's no content
to that statement a woman is a person
who believes they are a woman is you
know is anybody who believes they're a
blood well that doesn't mean anything
it's it's a blank it's a
self-referential statement and so you
know if you refuse to kowtow to that
ideology then the idea again is that
you're doing violence to a group of
people who say they are this thing
because you have not accepted their
their version of the world and either
you will change or they will change but
there is really no in between and so
yeah that's why all these conversations
don't end up being about public policy
questions they end up really being about
that fundamental idea are you of the
belief that a man can become a woman or
a woman can become a man and even deeper
than that is the belief are men and
women different from one another and
that's really the bigger question that
people can have really interesting
conversations because the answers are in
in some ways very very very different in
some ways not so different right but it
soon as you say in some ways very very
different a lot of people get very
offended very quickly because they want
to believe in the complete malleability
of every individual human being and they
want to believe in some sort of bizarre
world in this sort of Cartesian dualism
in which we are all disembodied Souls
that are that are walking around in meat
suits and those Souls can be male or
female and it's like Trading Places with
it's like a 1980s movie where you're
just going to be walking around and
suddenly you're in Mom's body or
something that's not how any of that
works and if you don't believe that that
is a religious point of view it's a
gnostic point of view actually and so if
you if you refuse to believe that and I
assume that you've attacked somebody's
religion yeah I you know I sometimes
just step back and I think imagine you
like I don't know had a car crash in
2010 and you were in a coma and then you
woke up in 2023 and the number one
question that everyone's talking about
is that they're arguing about what a
woman is right do you know someone
sometimes pinch yourself and go like
what it's insane I mean there is a clip
of Dennis Prager on Bill Maher I saw
that from
this is like seven years ago eight years
ago and Dennis is like yeah there's a
bunch of people and they won't even be
able to define the word woman and Mars
laughing at him everybody on the pound's
like what are you crazy what are you
talking about and now that it's being
preached by the White House I mean the
White House has taken that position
that's wild I mean the fact that this
has been elevated to a position of
national prominence is not because of
the right it's because the left decided
that this was going to be the core next
civil rights front is that they had
basically won on the same-sex marriage
issue and everybody thought okay battle
over like everybody weapons down go back
to your normal business like no no we
have another step here and the next step
is we're going to teach our version of
sexual orientation and gender identity
to your kids and that is going to
include the idea that gender is fully
malleable and on a spectrum and
completely socially constructed and
everybody I think moderate even Central
left and right was like uh hold up a
second and then it was well we're going
to use the exact same model we used for
the civil rights movement or for the gay
rights movement and we're going to say
that you're a bigot if you don't believe
this and people finally sort of Drew the
line like I'm not a bigot if I think
that women exist that doesn't make me a
bigot that was a line that nobody was it
so fundamentally runs up against the
proof of your eyes ears mind that to to
Simply surrender before it is to is to
become part of the Borg basically you
mentioned something about partisan
politics in that sort of right versus
left and that's something that I don't
know whether we are in disagreement or
not but certainly in the UK I feel we're
making more progress than you guys are
over here on the trans issue and I think
part of the reason is that in the UK we
have lots of people who are not
explicitly on the right on who frankly
on the left people like JK Rowling Rosie
Duffield the labor MP who's been very
outspoken about this not that it's
outspoken to say it right whereas here I
sort of you know I I do cringe when I
hear people sort of say the libs are
trans and the kids type of thing because
I don't think it's celebs that are trans
in the kids it's a small minority of
people who've captured institutions
who've shoved as gender ideology down
people's throats have used Scare Tactics
to bully them into not challenging it
but a lot of the people who are
challenging certainly in our country
it's not a partisan issue and I feel
that's why we're making progress whereas
here as you say on the one hand there
are a lot of people on the right who
sort of say the libs are trans and the
kids on the other hand the White House
is pushing this crap right I mean and
that that's sort of where you know it's
you can see why people will say I'll say
that that people are transiting the kids
typically I try to make it clear who
those people are and I think that when
the White House is actually promoting it
I'll say the White House is attempting
to trans the kids which they are um but
it's but the the kind of General point
that you're making which is that there
are people in public positions in
foreign countries who will say true
things even if it doesn't necessarily
fall into the right left dichotomy yeah
that doesn't apply in the United States
that is definitely true I mean really
since the era of
I wouldn't say Trump and I don't think
it actually is Trump I think it's really
since the era of Obama there's there's a
real shift that happened particularly in
the media space when Barack Obama was
elected president the media went from
yeah we're left wing but we understand
that there is a right wing in this
country too Barack Obama is the
lightbringer and we are his actual PR
agents and it is our job to basically
back what the President says and if you
don't back the president it must be
because you're a bigot right it must be
because there's something wrong with you
right and that that only got exacerbated
by Trump where suddenly The Washington
Post is emblazoning democracy dies in
darkness on on their on their Chiron or
whatever it is uh and um yeah the the
media are our real problem in all of
this I mean they you see how members of
the media just get absolutely shell act
if they step across the line the New
York Times are in one piece that was
fairly balanced about the trans issue
and the reporter got destroyed online
just destroyed you said a science
reporter got got fired for the great
crime of using the n-word while they
were in South America on a trip with
some people not because he was using the
envelope because he was explaining when
it is right and when it is wrong to use
the n-word you know the the the the
level of outrage that American society
is capable of achieving seems to be a
lot higher than it is in a lot of
European countries maybe that's because
there are such wide differentials in
sort of living in the United States and
the reality is that if the United States
was a critical country and if there is
sort of a central Creed to the United
States then the further that
disintegrates the more people sort of go
back to their Corners the United States
is not really an organic outgrowth I
mean it's it's it really is the the
blessing curse of the United States is
because it's not an organically grown
country right I mean you literally had a
European population that that is
imported into the United States or
Imports itself into the United States
and then you have various other
populations that come in in waves
rooted in this one idea if the idea dies
what do all those people exactly have in
common that's that's not really sort of
the case with Great Britain or France
when you think of of Great Britain you
think well yeah because they're British
when you think of an American what do
you think of I mean I really like if you
think of a British person you think the
person who has a British accent and
probably likes tea and maybe doesn't
have amazing teeth and like that there
are a bunch of things about the Brits
and and you think of Winston Churchill
you think of Margaret Thatcher on the
right and if you're not then you think
of Tony Blair or you think of you know
Gordon Brown you like there are people
that you think of and then if you go
back to British history you think of the
Royals right like there's an actual sort
of British culture that exists that just
doesn't exist in sort of the history of
the United States which is a which is so
deeply rooted in the idea of the
Constitution the idea of the Declaration
uh and and certain key personalities of
Washington and Lincoln that when you
destroy your history what you end up
with is everybody being like well you
know who I'm actually a member I'm a
member of my tribal group they kind of
came here together and I have in common
with those people but I'm not sure I
have that much in common with those
people over there there's a the
fundamental assimilative mechanism of
the United States has broken down and
and what that's done is it's led to this
sort of political fragmentation that I
think you don't really see in a lot of
other countries the United States is
people in the United States don't get
this but we are way more radical on a
wide variety of social policies than
pretty much anywhere I mean we're not
just radical with regards to the
transiting issue I mean we're very
radical with regard to the abortion
issue I mean it comes as an absolute
shock to people from Europe when they
realize that like the state of New York
allows abortion all the way up to birth
that in in most of Europe the average is
like 12 15 weeks with pretty
significance it's kind of a settled
issue we don't really argue about
abortion in in the UK or much of Europe
I mean occasionally you'll have
something like in Ireland where where
you know the Catholic Church sort of
gets overruled by the population or
whatever but in the United States
because again it's a very polarized
population the the vast majority of
Americans so I'm fully pro-life right I
want an abortion ban but I also
understand Republic opinion is in the
United States it does differ by area uh
and these sort of if you look at the
polls the mainstream opinion in the
United States just by pulling data is
very similar to the European position
it's like 10 12 15 weeks like that's
people beyond that people are like very
uncomfortable with abortion before that
people are like depends on the
circumstance the the reality is in the
United States because everything is
incredibly you know partisan and because
it's a huge country it's an enormous
country
people are they want to live how they
want to live in their area but the
federal government is where all the big
debates are happening it used to be that
you could actually have very wide
differences in ideas and standards of
living in Alabama and California but now
everything's been nationalized and the
federal government's incredibly powerful
and so what you have is a giant
overarching government and everybody is
fighting for control of that thing so
they can turn California into Alabama or
Alabama into California when the real
solution was actually the one the
founders presented which is the states
have most of the authorities and the
federal government really has very
little Frost before you jump in on that
very Point Ben that's such an
interesting point isn't the right the
small government right fundamentally at
a disadvantage in this situation then
because if the state the federal state
is becoming more and more powerful and
you guys believe in a smaller one your
opponents when they're in government are
inevitably a going to use it and be
making bigger yeah I mean this is the
argument that National conservatives are
making and they're they're making some
bad way with this argument they're
saying listen you can have all the
principles you want about about
shrinking the national government but
the minute the other guys get in power
they don't care about those principles
they're happy to just blow up as
government use those tools against you
and the answer to that is that when it
comes to the state level that's you
should have states that you know state
government of Florida has become very
active
in protecting you know kind of the
values and rights of the citizens of
Florida how they how they wish to vote
uh and I think that that's that's very
good I do not think that the the use of
the federal government at a a very you
know heavy level in order to implement
you know a conservative set of values is
likely to be successful I don't have I
don't have a general problem with it in
in sort of theory but in practice I
don't think that it's likely to work I
think that very often what you end up
with is the American public I think for
the most part like any like any Western
public just wants to they want normalcy
and predictability and to be left alone
that's mostly what most people want
um and I think that the the battle over
government is swinging wildly from this
direction to that direction what the
American people keep saying we want
right here right just just
predictability leave us I mean we
elected a dead person specifically for
this
for this purpose right we're like it's
we went from Barack Obama Library like
we don't need a lightbringer you know
bringing the guy who's like the business
guy who's an outsider we don't want
Hillary because she's just corrupt and
terrible we're bringing this Outsider
we'll give that a try and maybe that'll
be normal like oh boy this wasn't normal
at all let's go let's get the dead guy
maybe and they bring in the animated
corpse of Joe Biden it's not normal at
all and people are like well maybe we'll
get back to normal and the right's like
well screw those people we're going to
bring back in the guy who was ousted by
that guy and so it's kind of wildly
vacillating and it's wildly vacillating
mainly because the people who are most
political engaged are the people who are
most politically engaged and the vast
majority of people in the middle who
show maybe only for presidential
elections are then presented with a
binary choice between the the people of
either party who may not be the most
normal people and I think that this
keeps being
I actually think that this is not just a
theme in the United States I think it
seems to be like a theme across Western
Civilization right now is people are
just looking for a politician who's like
can we just be normal for a second or
just something relatively like I know
what's happening tomorrow and I don't
have to pay attention to you but you
know so long as we have a national media
that thrives on this sort of conflict
it's going to be very difficult to
achieve that I think absolutely and if
you look at this in the Matt Walsh
situation we demand that our politicians
never say anything controversial never
do anything controversial and then we're
surprised when we get these weird people
for election it's because everybody else
does normal things and says things that
are controversial and makes mistakes and
whatever else
but the question that I really want to
ask to you Ben is do you think the right
concentrate too much on the trans issue
and I'm not saying the trans issue is
not highly important it is highly
important and understand the aspects of
it but you look at you know we've got a
fentanyl crisis in this country
shouldn't the right also be talking
about that and everything like and
everything else I think a lot of these
problems are overlaid onto far deeper
systemic problems so I think that very
often in politics we argue about the
things that are at the top of the
iceberg but we very rarely get to the
bottom of the iceberg so the thing that
I would say that the fentanyl crisis and
maybe the Francis you have in common is
that the the thing that has been
dissolving in American life for a very
long time is the fundamental family
structure and the fundamental family
structure dissolves what you end up with
the atomistic individuals atomistic
individuals make bad decisions they tend
to be depressed they tend to be upset
they tend to they tend to be volatile
and so a huge variety of issues in
America are just aspects of this ranging
from school shootings to the fentanyl
crisis to Broken families in higher
crime rates to the transition right all
of these things are as social fabric
Falls away then sort of the nakedness of
the of the the you know raw Humanities
is left Unleashed and and you're seeing
a lot of aspects of that so I don't
think that they're utterly unrelated I
think that people like to talk about the
transition on both sides because it's a
it's an issue with with like very very
clear demarcated lines and so that's a
fun issue to talk about because if
you're on the right you look at this
joke this is just crazy I could talk
about this all day how crazy this is
because it's so crazy and if you're on
the left of the God those intolerant
bigots I love calling them bigots this
is my favorite thing is to call them
bigots and so it's a fun issue for
people to talk about fentanyl is is a
less fun issue to talk about for people
not just because it involves Mass death
but also because it actually implicates
some deeper issues that make people very
uncomfortable uh you're actually going
to have to talk about things like is
this happening because of you know as
the right will maintain sometimes trade
and the Outsourcing manufacturing jobs
or is this actually happening because of
the thing that very few people want to
touch maybe across the aisle which is no
one goes to church anymore fewer and
fewer kids are growing up with two
parents in a household there there's no
social fabric there's no social
structure there's no one to keep an eye
on these kids you know what when and
that when that happens what that perhaps
men losing the role in society as
protectors and providers for their
family actually unmoors them and makes
them depressed and more likely to get
into drug use right like these are
really deep kind of fundamental
philosophic issues and I think most
people tend to shy away from those
because it's not as fun right it's not
it's not as memeable it's not as kind of
tick-tockable and it again it gets to
some really uncomfortable things about
individualism in the age of the
post-enlightenment right I mean like
what I'm talking about is actual things
that create obligations and duties for
people right I'm talking about now like
what you should do with your life I'm
not just talking about what you
shouldn't do or what's stupid I'm
talking about like the things that you
should do in life to make a thriving
society and that comes with actual rules
it comes with things you have to do and
then you say to somebody this comes with
obligation people go I I right because
if you say you know the way to prevent
the fentanyl crisis it's not just an
easy thing about like bombing cartels
the way you have to prevent the fentanyl
crisis is that you actually have to
provide thriving family structures in
religious communities in which people
feel comfortable looking for help but
also can find a wife can have children
are expected to do these things and that
means leaving behind the the things of
childhood and actually taking on an
obligation to live more fulfilled and
better life not just for yourself but
for your community because without that
social Fabric and you taking part in
building that social fabric it doesn't
just fall apart for you it falls apart
for everybody people immediately go wait
you want me to do a thing I I didn't
sign up for this I signed up to listen
to a political show right I signed up to
watch CNN I signed up to watch Fox News
I signed up to watch like you know
somebody yell at how if I just changed
this politician then that'll fix the
thing this is why I think there's so
much faith in politicians which is also
why everything is polarized no one
should have faith in politicians
politicians are representatives of the
people which means inherently that if
you worship a politician you're an idol
worshiper you're actually worshiping
yourself you elect the politician then
you mold the gold link after your
specifications and then you worship it
and you say why isn't it doing the thing
I wanted to do and if only I just
replaced this golden calf with that
golden calf then that would be better
but perhaps the real work that we all
have to do is not just solved by going
into the voting booth and pulling the
lever on a particular politician maybe
the actual work that we have to do is
the hard work of getting up at three
o'clock in the morning with your kids
and doing your homework with your kids
and fun and and battling through
whatever hardships you have in your
marriage to maintain your marriage and
then taking care of your parents as they
get older and making sure that the
people in your community if they're
coming on Hard Times actually have
something to fall back on but also
making sure that they're incentivized to
go out and work again like these are
actually the hard everyday things and in
you know my belief is obviously I'm an
orthodox Jew I think in the absence of
religious structure it's very difficult
to promote these things um but you know
those are again conversations they also
believe in fact Ben and the fact of it
is that most people are are increasingly
less religious in Western Society right
so I was going to ask you this because
of course I understand and by the way we
spend time with religious conservatives
you know and so it's it's wonderful to
see the positive signs of that you know
all of the things you've just talked
about and they are I agree with you a
hundred percent those things are
incredibly important for society to
thrive but the fact is you know we've
had different guests on the show Louise
Perry and Mary Harrington talking about
the sexual Revolution and how that
unleashes all of this process 60s
onwards but yours I all I'm saying is I
put it to you that your solution which
is right for you and right for Many
religious people in this country is
increasingly less taken up whether you
and I like it or not I agree with you so
what do we do about that how do we
encourage people who are not religious
you know when Peterson had me on his
podcast we talked about a lot of this
how do you instill some of the values in
a society that doesn't believe in God as
much right so I mean I think Jordan is
really great about this which is the
idea that you take on obligations to do
something higher and then you'll find
yourself doing something so do the thing
right in front of me I think Jordan is
really great at this
um you know as an orthodox student a
proponent of my own religion obviously I
think my my religion is very
Aristotelian in its approach to life
which is you get up in the morning and
there's a bunch of things you have to do
and if you do those things then you'll
grow increasingly virtuous and you'll
grow increasingly close to God now you
can be Aristotelian not really bring God
into it very much you can say you can
grow increasingly close to Virtue I
think that's stepping one short
logically because then the question is
how do you define virtue where does
virtue come from is there an objective
standard a virtual or is it all just
moral relativism that's why I'm
religious but if if you don't wish to go
there if you just wish to stop at that
step without going to God or without
going to church or any of that stuff
first of all you're going to have to
find a community of people who agree
with you people who actually want to
build that Community with you maybe
they're not so religious but they have
the same set of values as you do uh and
then you're going to have to and then
you're going to have to actually
undertake those obligations in a really
methodical and thought out way now the
reason I say that religion provides a
structure is because traditionally that
has been the structure now what's
fascinating is that you can be a
non-religious person living in a society
that values religion and a lot of that
stuff sort of bleeds over to you through
the water with Ross Moses so here I'll
take the example of Israel what's
fascinating about Israel is that Israel
has a reproduction rate of currently
something like three okay it is the only
Western country that is reproducing
above replacement rates literally the
only one and it's not just reproducing
at the rate of of three there's a huge
disparity between people who are
religious and the people who are secular
but the so the people who are the most
religious like the haridium the ultra
Orthodox they're having their own
routine they think they're averaging
seven kids the the people who are dates
me which is you know religious Zionist
which is probably where I would fall if
I were living in Israel that they're
having like four to five kids right I
have three I'm having a fourth that's
fairly typical uh and then the the
seculars the seculars are having three
kids why are the seculars having three
kids they're the only secular people
anywhere in the western world who are
having three kids why and the answer is
because the entire culture values having
children when you see people having kids
around you're like that's cool I would
also like to have kids it seems like
that'd be amazing maybe two kids isn't
enough my the guy across the street has
eight they seem amazing like they they
they're really happy and so you see that
sort of bleed down so even if you're not
I think that you can have a society in
which you have Voltaire so long as
voltaire's recognize what Voltaire did
which is I don't believe in God but I
sure hope I made does right otherwise
she'll steal the silverware
so the the as but I think that as
Western Civilization becomes
increasingly individualistic and
anti-religious it's not just like sort
of apathetic about religion it's it's
become antagonistic toward religion I
think that that bleeds over into a
secular world that was living off sort
of the fumes of a religious Society but
as those fumes dissipate well you end up
with his what do I do this morning how
do I get up what is the moral obligation
what what's in it for me okay so the
religious ideal was always and this is
why again you can do the stoic thing
right there's still philosophers who say
you get up in the morning you do virtue
that's great that may work for for some
people I hope it works for a lot of
people right that I think it's a
valuable belief that's the rule I think
I take inferences too yeah I mean I
think that there are people who want to
do that I think that's that's great
that's wonderful I think for the vast
majority of people throughout human
history again the thing that orients you
is the idea that when you get up and you
have a duty it's not a duty just because
you think it's good to have the duty
it's a duty because you are enjoying to
do the thing right what makes you so
I'll ask you guys I mean like what what
makes you do the thing you don't want to
do right you have an 11 month old baby
so having a lot of kids I I you know
it's it's
it's a pain in the ass right I mean like
having it there they're wonderful as I
always say to people in life when you're
a single dude basically you're you're
sort of spectrum of Happiness to to
sadness is like a 10 to a zero and then
you get married and it goes from like a
20 to a negative 20. because if
something bad happens your spouse it's
really terrible and then you have kids
and all limits are removed the best
things in your life will be your kids
and the worst things by far in your life
will be your kids it's it's really tough
I mean parenting is not an easy thing so
what motivates you that you know it's
three o'clock in the morning your kid
took a dump and now you have to change
the diaper what makes you get up as
opposed to just turning over and saying
your life you know you deal with it I'm
going back to sleep well for me the duty
is that is an obligation I took upon
myself when we decided to have a child
that's what I signed up to do so why so
why did you do that well what drove what
drove you to make that decision because
that's the question because people
increasingly are not making the decision
to have to get married and then even if
they do get married have kids right
we're an all-time low in terms of people
getting married and having kids I I look
my view is there's a biological
explanation for why we all want to have
kids right so so and actually my wife
and I put it off quite quite late
probably a little bit later than we
would have done I'd love to bang out
five as well at this point uh but anyway
for me uh I I think it's the biological
drive to procreate so the the only
problem with that is that that was true
and it was maintained before the birth
control pill right because the
biological drive to procreate so two
things happen the birth control pill and
the feminist movement so there are two
real drives men had babies because they
couldn't stop having babies and women
had babies because not only could they
not stop having babies they actually
wanted to have babies and they were in
touch with the idea that it is good for
a woman to have a baby now I have entire
movements that teach women that the
highest form of life is don't get
married until you're close to 30 if you
do get married
if it's going to inhibit your career
then you should probably freeze your
eggs and wait until you're maybe 40.
then you have a risky pregnancy at 40 in
which we you know fertilize the egg and
maybe implanted in you and that's like
the apotheosis of civilization and women
by all available polling data are
significantly less happy than they were
preaching to the choir I said something
completely innocuous about this on
Twitter I've been dealing with feminists
and giving me [__] for a week now so I'm
familiar with that I mean but the bottom
line is that how do you reverse that so
they're only in two ways especially
because you can see I mean as countries
get richer and as birth control becomes
more plentiful the the original pitch
for having kids was twofold one you had
a religious obligation to have kids and
two was they were labor on your farm
right those were the original now kids
are at cost it cost you a lot of money
to have a child it is not an economic
not only that you had kids because when
you got old they were going to take care
of you now you have social welfare nuts
they take care of you so what's the
economic case for how there's no
economic cases it disappeared it's now
reverse economic case if you want to
live high on the hog you don't have kids
you go to vacation in Rome but you don't
have kids and so that's a real problem
but how do you overcome that and so then
it has to be something like a woman
desperately wants to have kids
and the only way that she is going to
have kids if she makes the rules that a
man has to marry her in order to have
the kids so you have to overcome two
things societally one you have to teach
women it's good to have kids and two you
have to teach women that actually men's
standards for sex are the wrong
standards for sex that if you wish to
have long lasting fulfilling
relationships then hopping in and out of
the sack with people isn't actually a
form of Liberation it's a form of it's a
form of bondage to a certain extent
you're training yourself to how males
tend to think about sex rather than what
is fulfilling for females a biological
function that has existed for literally
all of humankind's existence these are
these are heavy lifts it seems to me
that the shortcut on these lifts which
is proved out by literally every
demographic study done in the west is
that if you say God told you to have
kids you have a duty to have kids it is
good to have kids and you're you're
trained in that from the time you're
little like my kids again right now
they're nine by the time they're seven
and and three and in the womb and I
asked my three-year-old daughter how
many kids she wants to have like it's
ingrained in her it's ingrained like my
son I'll ask him how many kids he wants
to he'll say I want to have four kids
right because we're gonna have four kids
like that's the way works I ask you know
like you actually have to bring your
kids up in this way and which is why
across Western Society there are
exceptions who will do the thing you'll
do the thing you'll do like people will
do the thing but that's a lot rarer if
you look at the demographic profiles the
only people the only populations in the
west reproducing it above replacement
rates are in the United States for
example Mormons religious Catholics
religious Jews religious Muslims
religious Protestants that's it no one
else is reproducing it above replacement
rates
so unless those are like the bulk of
your population and then it's sort of
those values sort of bleed over into the
rest of the population which is not the
case in the United States then you know
you're going to have a declining birth
rate and then you're gonna have to do it
through immigration then that's going to
come with whatever attendant problems
Mass immigration comes with right
demographic problems are a real thing do
you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be cancel culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
but why is it so taboo to talk about
these things about things like
immigration why is it that it's so
charged instead of just having a
reasonable debate and saying look like
every decision you make in life there
are trade-offs right well that's the
thing no one in politics actually wants
to talk about trade-offs every solution
is going to be the solution that fixes
all the things and it's an immature way
of thinking about politics the the truth
is that like everything that we do is
going to have costs and benefits but
politicians are in the business of lying
to you and again this goes back to if
you get your values from politicians
you're likely to have a very skewed set
of values politicians have no incentive
to tell you about trade-offs they have
incentives to tell you that if you vote
for them they will celebrate I mean
Trump literally said this he said I only
I can only I can fix right and Joe Biden
says the same thing from his angle if
you elect me all your problems will go
away it'll be sunny days from here on in
they're all lying I mean that's not true
but apparently we want to be lied to
Because the actual thing that fixes your
life is you I mean this is this is true
for 95 of our problems yeah they're
problems that are unsolvable health
problems terrible things that have
tragedies that occur in life all that's
true but 95 of the problems that people
have are problems that are generally
within their purview and by the way you
should treat even the problems that you
have that are not within approve you as
though you could possibly solve them
because it's a better way of approaching
life but politics allows you to
Outsource all of that it allows you to
say listen the problem is not me the
problem is the system and if I just
select this guy to fix the system that
and and that what does that create the
incentive for him to do to say that he's
going to fix the system right and then
he fails and then we get disappointed
and then we radically shift over maybe
that guy will fix the system oh no he's
not working well maybe that guy will fix
the system none of them are going to fix
the system because fundamentally in
terms of like human freedoms and
Prosperity right now the system ain't
broken there are real problems with the
system but we are the most prosperous
free people in the history of the world
like Bar None it is not closed if you I
mean when you talk about you know
dropping someone from 2010 and 2023 and
they're looking at the base going what
is this but think of it a different way
you drop somebody from 1810 into 2023
they're living in magic land man I mean
this is a place where you pick up a
piece of phone that you pick up a thing
that it's a magic thing in your hand
that connects you to every piece of
information ever devised you hit a
button and a thing arrives at your door
usually within 24 hours that has been
outsourced to 27 different countries and
arrives for a fraction of the money that
you make in a month I mean that's magic
that's magic you're ever You're
Expecting like if somebody dies at
anywhere like oh man they probably had
another 10. I mean that's that's crazy
that's crazy for the vast majority of
human civilization people died you know
at the age if you were lucky you made it
to 60. but people were dying at 50 or
make it out of childhood right huge huge
the amount of childhood death has
declined so radically that you know it
used to be that that you know childhood
death was was a tragedy but it wasn't
treated nearly the way that it's treated
today because again we expect children
to live now right like all of these
standards are magical so the question is
how can the magical material living
standards be so high and we're able to
do kind of what we want like on a daily
basis walk out your front door nobody's
telling you what to do and yet we're
wildly unhappy right we have depression
suicidality huge fentanyl crises we're
worried about the I mean the problems
we're talking about are real problems
we've apparently lost our societal Minds
because we're believing complete
untruths we're so angry at each other
that we're willing to ensure the death
threats over whether men or women or
women or men you know like what where is
that coming from and the answer is the
social fabric that undergirded all that
progress has fallen away and we thought
we could have all of the nice things
that a lie on top of the foundation
while taking a jackhammer to the
foundations and so people don't want to
talk about the foundations because it
might mean that you have to I I got a
question a lot so I obviously I talk
about religion a lot and people say I
don't believe in God but I have kids
should I go to church and my answer is
yes you should go to church if you're if
you if you grew up Christian and that's
your religion you should go to church
because you know what that may be the
way that your kid understands the values
the best it's very difficult to make a
sophisticated argument with a year old
it really is when they're 20 and they
have questions about God and they say
listen I can't get there you can say
like listen I'll make an argument for
God but maybe you don't want to maybe
that's not your thing fine but you know
who can't handle that argument a
three-year-old yeah
and niceness is not a moral value system
it really isn't Ben there's a question
that I want to ask the the thing or the
slogan or the words that people always
associate with you are facts don't care
about your feelings
but isn't there an issue with that
statement in that
feelings are the most important things
we have which is why the left is winning
because they make you feel good and it's
actually really not about facts anymore
it's about the way I make you feel and
if you look at our entire conversation
it really is about that you know if you
think about kids kids don't always make
you feel great and you know they're
going to challenge you you want someone
to come in and solve your problems why
is that because
confronting your problems doesn't make
you feel good in fact it makes you feel
sometimes inadequate isn't that really
the problem here yes I mean it's why so
the other phrase that I've been fun of
using a lot over the past couple years
is reality always wins so here's the
thing facts don't care about your
feelings and the facts are going to win
it's just a question of if you're stupid
enough to run up against them enough
times in a row uh and so when I say
facts don't care about your feelings I
don't mean that you know you're not that
your feelings don't matter what I do
mean is that if you if you are running
directly up against the wall effect over
and over and over in reality over and
over and over and over then you're going
to break those things reality doesn't
change just because you wish for it to
change and so my friend Andrew Clay then
he's very fond of saying people are you
know a woman will come to me I can't
find Mr Right and say well did you make
yourself Mrs Right yet right like if you
want to find Mr Right you have to be Mrs
Right you have to make yourself the
thing people don't want this they want
the standard to change the World to
Change for them and the world is not
going to change for you the world is
just the world you can effectuate small
changes over time in the course of the
world you know this is uh the truth is
that the vast majority of change we
because we're in politics we tend to
think of like great figures who
effectuated large scale change the truth
is there are millions of people who
stand behind those people and most
change that occurs is really a bunch of
people whose names you don't know at the
graveyard and who are completely
forgotten now right those are people who
are like changing their society From the
Inside by doing the things that we're
that we're talking about it's a lot less
glorious you're right I mean this is the
problem but I don't see a way of
combating that with more feelings
meaning I so I think that it's a mistake
for example for conservatives to talk
about if you do these things then you
will be happier
because I don't know whether you'll be
happier I think I know that you'll be
more fulfilled
but I don't like the word happier
because I think that happy is a is a a
it's a messy word you feel happy when
you have an ice cream
right
the words that are used by the Ancients
you know eudemonia or in in Greek or
simcha in Hebrew like the these sorts of
those sorts of words have broader
meanings right it didn't just mean like
you feel good one day but we're Society
to sort of boiled down happiness do you
feel good that day and that's a really
bad standard because what makes you feel
good today is not going to make you feel
good in the long run I mean very often I
was just reading a study actually by a
social sciences named Roy Baumeister and
he was looking at things that make
people feel fulfilled versus things that
make people feel happy and very often
there's overlap but there are certain
areas where there's no overlap so for
example things that make you feel happy
but not fulfilled would be things like
parties right you go to parties it might
make you happy in the moment but does
make you feel very fulfilled it's just a
night whatever things that make you not
happy but extremely difficult having
kids having kids is number one on the
list of things that make you not happy
but extremely fulfilled which is true
having kids is not a happy it has happy
moments joyous moments but overall it's
a slog and people need to know that
getting in but it's also the most
important thing that you're ever going
to do important is a word that's totally
left our sort conversation no one talks
about doing anything because it implies
the existence of a moral structure
correct it implies there's certain
things you're doing that are unimportant
yeah and you can't say that to me what I
do every day is important no it isn't
right notice in the vast majority of
things you do in a given day are not
important Ben we're running out of time
unfortunately so a couple more questions
before we go to locals having
established that politicians don't
matter as much as personal Behavior
nonetheless I have to ask you we're
sitting here in Florida uh you guys are
going to have an election the next
couple of years uh the governor of this
state Ron DeSantis is very likely to
challenge Donald Trump for the
nomination who do you back into Santa's
why because do you want this from the
why not Donald Trump or the why rotten
yeah I mean they're they're two so two
two sort of angles first of all I'll
preface this with whoever is the
Republican nominee I'm a conservative
I'm very likely to vote for them now as
between DeSantis and Trump we'll start
with the shortcomings of trump he's 76
years old he has no ability to control
his mouth or his typing fingers he has
no sort of actual plan to win I mean he
literally complained in 2020 that he was
robbed of the election through voter
fraud but no one will ask him a simple
question how do you plan to unrob the
election in 2024 right like what's your
plan for victory he I did ask that of
his former deputy assistant
well you people will have to wait and
see
he's trailing in every swing state poll
he he is um wildly unpopular with
Independence he's wildly unpopular with
women he has an approval rating last I
checked in the 20s and he is 76 years
old and he already served a term I mean
that that is that pretty formidable list
of reasons why you don't nominate and he
lost to the guy who's going to run on
the Democratic party side already by
seven million votes and by the available
data he will probably underperform how
he performed in 2020. at least with
again one of the hardest things in
politics is to switch somebody's mind
saying to millions of people yeah you
voted for me in 2016. then you voted
against me in 2020 and now I want you to
switch back and vote for me that's not
even switching Minds once that's
switching mines twice that's that's
super difficult so you know that that's
a hard thing
um you know and that's putting aside All
The Oddities and all the rest of the
scandals and all that kind of stuff the
case for DeSantis is that DeSantis is
extremely meticulous about how he
approaches politics you see for example
there are no leaks from his campaign
because he actually staffs up correctly
as opposed to Trump who's going on Truth
social and bashing somebody he hired as
an idiot every other day he hired them
this hands actually doesn't have any
leaks he hires a team he's very
meticulous about it when he focuses in
an issue he really focuses on an issue
he is good at actually governing so the
the dirty little secret about Florida is
to really well governed state right we
have all the cultural War stuff that
makes the national media but the stuff
that doesn't make the national media is
that when there's a hurricane we're
rebuilding Bridges within like a day
right the problems actually get solved
here that desensis brought down crime
rates dramatically that he offered
police officer a ten thousand dollar
stipend to move into the state then in
in the State of Florida if you have a
kid who's going to to school you have
available to you now as of July like an
eight thousand dollar School tax credit
so you can actually take your kid out of
a public school if you want to and move
them to the local private school if you
think that that's a better school I mean
these are very good things for people
who are living in the State of Florida
which is why it's the number one
incoming state for populations he's very
good at just like the pure governance of
it and then on sort of the culture
warfront he's taking on a lot of the
culture wars in a way that really
animates the base the base doesn't want
a Mitt Romney type who's going to be you
know sort of double Stitch water really
glossy they want somebody who's willing
to get in the trenches and fight which
is why he's very popular in the
primaries right now because the media
chose him as sort of its opponent and
that was over covid where he happened to
be right and the left happened to be
completely wrong on that using Andrew
Cuomo whose two missions in life were
killing old people and grabbing ass and
he ran out of old people you know the
the
DeSantis has has you know his governance
during covid keeping the state open
keeping the economy running was against
all of what the media was saying and he
succeeded with that so that that's a
really good case for desensis now listen
their flaws with the stances to Canada
he's not nearly as sort of magnetic As
Trump because no one is I mean Trump is
just like it's a he's been on TV for
years and years and years and years and
the camera's just drawn to him
um you know I think that the battle for
for Trump is going to be between the
fact that he's magnetic and the fact
that he's extraordinarily tiring like if
you've seen him too much everybody's
just like oh like I can't I can't with
this and for this answers the battle is
going to be how do you keep people
interested because he's very pugilistic
but he's like an amazing speaker or
something he's not super personable
Trump's a big people person he likes
ripping people you know and giving them
a hug and he likes or at least shaking
their hand he likes going out in public
he likes the adulation he likes
interactions that's not to San Francisco
sense this is a lot more kind of
reserved as a person and so that's
that's an uphill battle for him but he
also knows how to run a government and
if he gets into the presidency then he
presumably will not allowed the quote
unquote deep States thwart him he'll
just go on a fire a bunch of people he
was in Congress he's been a governor he
knows how to run things so that's the
case for DeSantis and I think also
against Trump and what would you say to
those people who say DeSantis simply
doesn't have the cut through with
ordinary people like Trump does uh I
mean I don't know who the ordinary
people are so I think that that's that's
it's true that Trump for let's say blue
collar conservative white voters there's
nobody gonna be like Trump no one I mean
like Trump has a magic with this group
it's not an insignificant group of
people by any measure but the question
for those people is going to be do you
want to vote for the guy you love but
who's likely to lose or join to vote for
somebody who you like but his
significant more likely to win and that
really is going to have to be the
question for people I mean I I had this
conversation with the guy the other day
and he's like yeah I think this answer
is a better shot there's Wall Street
Journal poll that came out this week
that says the same thing 41 of
Republican voters say DeSantis is more
likely to be Biden 31 say Trump that
same poll showed 51 voting for Trump in
the primaries versus 38 for DeSantis
it's like who are these 20 of people who
don't think that that Trump is likely to
win but will vote for him in a primary
who are those people like that's such a
weird thing you're going to vote from
him in the primary knowing that he's
likely to lose like that seems that
seems very strange to me I think that
people have to get over this um this
sort of
weird dream-esque equality that they
have about Trump which is that he's sort
of a miracle worker and again I think
that that actually goes back to 2012. um
because in 2012 when Romney ran and
Obama was unpopular and Romney lost the
Democrats decided they were never going
to lose another election and Republicans
also thought Democrats are never going
to lose another election they've built a
new minority majority Coalition with
some college-educated white people
they're never going to lose they've got
this thing from here on and that was the
theme for Hillary and then Trump wins
and everybody's brain just breaks the
left goes it must have been the Russians
the Russians must have stolen this thing
the right goes he must be a wizard I
mean there's no way for us there's no
way for us to win I mean look at this he
he lost by you know three million votes
but he pulled exactly like right in this
place like uh you know the the bolts hit
from Zeus and suddenly he's president
like that's the man works miracles and
then 2020 happens and now the
presuppositions are challenged again so
the left goes well maybe you know our
Coalition is more durable than we
thought it was in 2016. and the right
goes well maybe he's not a miracle
worker and then Trump says I didn't lose
well maybe he's a miracle worker who got
who got stiffed right he's still a
miracle worker and so the question for a
lot of Republicans is going to be do you
still think he's a miracle worker do you
think that he's being jobbed or do you
think that like political gravity
applies and he won one election and then
he lost like three elections he lost
2018 he lost 2020 he lost 2022 like that
those are those are three elections he
did not do well in Ben we're about to
ask you a few questions from our
supporters on locals but we always end
the show with the final question the
same one for our guest which is what do
you think is the one thing we're not
talking about that we really should be I
mean I I think that was probably the
first 40 minutes it was yeah I mean the
the thing that we break down as a family
and mainly the the duties that you have
as an individual in your daily life how
do you get up in the morning and do
those things because that's how you
actually change a society it's not it's
not with all the stuff I talk about on a
daily basis and that stuff is important
but the stuff that's significantly more
important is how you get up and interact
with the people in your life what sort
of Duties you perform what obligations
you undertake to make the the social
structure more secure and also to
provide for for a future that that's
that's the thing that matters Ben thank
you so much for joining us for the show
thank you guys for watching and
listening head over to locals for the
bonus questions and we'll see you there
take care and see you soon guys
Ben while your stance on guns is
understandable in a U.S context would
you recommend more guns in other
countries for example UK Australia New
Zealand for example
[Music]
foreign